oh hello river babes and kisses to you
all for coming back I'm your Riverdale
loving host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode 215 chapter 28 there will be
blood and as always I'll be breaking
down your hisses and kisses from the
last episode and since you all really
seem to enjoy these three clues I gave
you in last week's preview show I'm
going to do it again so get excited for
that
I love Archie in the whole game but
right now what I'm most excited about
are all the comments that you River
babes have been leaving me after each
and every episode
in fact our YouTube specialists just
told me that out of all the shows on
entertainment tonight's YouTube channel
Sweetwater Secrets has the most active
comment section so thank you guys so
much you're making me so proud so to
celebrate here are some of my favorite
comments that you left on chapter 27 The
Hills Have Eyes kicking things off
Daphne Allen wrote kisses to Shoni I
ship it so hard it's so nice to see a by
slash less relationship as romantic
instead of all sex not that there's
anything wrong with that
love the build-up this episode as a
whole just major kisses all the
characters were so well represented and
so many questions were answered favorite
episode yes and of course kisses to the
robbers rich Sommer folks never learn
don't ask me I don't know if that was a
typo and you meant to say kisses to the
robbers but if you really meant kisses
then I applaud your savage stance and
hey at least the robbers got the core
floor to stop fighting
and Austin Harvey added and I the only
one who found it ironic that while the
kids were playing Monopoly Hiram was
doing it in real life
Riverdale underscore maa commented a
major hist to the fact that the writers
haven't brought back the black hood
plotline for a while but kisses to Abby
and V moment praise Jesus
sorry not sorry I'm glad the black hood
storyline is gone for now and D nian
said I laughed so hard when Archie told
Veronica wouldn't that be like their
12th breakup of this year shave
meanwhile Caroline 21 posted I don't
[ __ ] Veronica with Archie or Jughead I
want her to date Reggie okay but here's
the problem Caroline has anyone seen
Reggie anyone know practice is canceled
and lastly Jackie Lopez wrote alright
this might sound crazy but I feel like
chick is not really chick but that he's
pretending to be him interesting now I
can't comment on this amazingly
insightful theory Jackie but all I can
say is you should watch this week's
episode thank you tell anyone it'll be
bad for Betty and Alice
moving on to focus on this week's
episode chapter xxviii there will be
blood we know from the promo that Hyrum
is pissed at an inner-circle snitch
Archie Polly is back and meeting chick
for the first time awkward and Alice
Cooper is dropping some serious savagery
on the blossoms yeah that's right I said
inbred but I know you want more so here
are three hints about episode 215 to
tide you over until it premieres number
one the exact phrase I'm going to kill
you will be dropped and you'll gasp when
you see who says it I know I did number
two with mayor McCoy no longer ruling
Riverdale it's time for a new River
parent to step into the political
spotlight but who has what it takes and
number three while one couples romance
slowly begins to blossom what is going
on here
another twosomes love will be tested
again oh and what the heck just for
funsies here's one more alright number
four a shocking character returns to
town and this could change everything it
changes everything
there you go over there babes now check
back to Sweetwater secrets after you
watch chapter 28 there will be blood for
a full breakdown of the episodes most
jaw-dropping moments plus a fun
explanation for my outfit inspiration of
the week but for now hit the comments
and see if you can decipher my for clues
then give this video a like and hit
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel so
we can all fix eight on the craziness of
Riverdale together
[Music]